whether you drink it dripped pressed
steamed or iced these are some of the
beans that wake up half of the planet
every morning
and it's water that turns them into your
favorite type of coffee
but in the hills of kudagu Southwest
India where coffee beans grow water
often ruins production
there is either too much or too little
all as a result of climate change
this year there's been 40 percent less
rainfall than usual during the monsoon
season and that's having a direct and
costly impact on these coffee Farmers
last year a crop was done about 40 to 50
percent you know because of the erratic
rain patterns and we got rains when rain
shouldn't have come you know during the
harvest season so many of the coffee
cherries that you see because of the
rains it starts dropping and once it
drops the quality degrades also so that
was a major concern last year the year
before that we had very less strains
creating irrigation systems and
mechanical drying methods to combat the
change in climate is expensive
Rajesh is a small-scale farmer he has a
10 Acre Coffee Farm where he also grows
other crops after whether patterns
started shifting he switched to focusing
on the Robusta Bean a decade ago more
resilient than the more sensitive but
more in demand Arabica
up to fruit picking India's coffee is
the best in the world but after picking
it becomes the worst coffee in the world
to cure it is a very expensive process
small farmers like me we can't afford it
farmers can join a collective that
shares and pools resources making
production cheaper but it's expensive to
meet all the criteria and only around
one to two percent of those in the
region have signed up
this is a collective coffee curing
facility beans are cleaned processed and
graded though our coffees are one of the
best the world is failed to recognize
probably we also did not tell the right
story but I'm happy to tell you that
slowly that market awareness is taking
place Indian Robusta slowly started
getting traction and it has been
recognized as one of the good coffees at
par with Arabica in most of the times
so we are hopeful that the days are very
green for us
it seems Farmers here are now more
determined to better Market their coffee
abroad but the weather and the climate
will have to help
Stephanie Decker Al Jazeera
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera